the white house acting like it's no big
deal that these covid positive texas
democrats are spreading the virus
around like wildfire all over washington
after flying masculists six of those
lawmakers now testing positive for kovit
19.
along with a white house aide and a
pelosi staff are linked to them
but the white house is refusing to call
them super spreaders
while scolding the rest of america over
a rise in cases
is there any concern that this trip that
was intended to advocate for voting
rights is now a super spreader event in
washington
well i would say that's not a
characterization we're making from here
scenes that are incredibly effective are
not foolproof
we know that these vaccines that these
individuals i think if i'm correct have
have been vaccinated
that is a good sign and where's the
media to condemn these lawmakers and
accuse them of putting lives at risk
they had no problem doing it with
republicans
he's moving ahead with a huge indoor
event despite a record one-day increase
of corona virus cases
in that state and warnings that israeli
could be a super spreader of the virus
all of these people packed in what could
be a
coveted super spreader event at the
white house president trump is doing
these rallies
the people are not wearing masks i mean
these are super spreader events
potentially
all right katie it is interesting you
know pelosi what is she third in line
yeah kamala harris second one and uh
there was a little bit of impact there
i wrote some headlines that the media
would have written if this were
president trump so
i hope we're ready for these the first
is how many people have to die
before texas democrats keep take cove
but seriously
texas democrats are literally killing
people by denying their mask wearing
science deniers endangered the lives of
the vice president and speaker of the
house
after maskless anti-science stand
on this it's like the bottom line is
you're allowed to not follow the rules
if you're a democrat
advocating against voter id according to
the white house and if the media and
democrats hadn't made covid so political
maybe more people would have been on
board with some of the measures and
everything else but because they made it
all about politics and using it as a
political weapon in an election year
now they're looking pretty bad when it
comes to this stint that they pulled on
this private jet where they
didn't wear masks and then went to meet
with some of the most important and
powerful people
in the country digging i feel like
there's a lot of unanswered questions
about this
i love saying there's a lot of
unanswered questions makes me sound
really smart
that should be a show for you unanswered
answer questions
we'd never get to the bottom of anything
i promise
but if everybody's vaccinated allegedly
how do they get
six coven positive tests how does that
happen what are the chances of that
happening
we've all sucked face with an
inappropriate person
at some time i don't know but i think
somebody's not telling the truth
so it seems weird the whole story stinks
aside i talked about it yeah i mentioned
it earlier in the week that the
breakthrough cases seem to be
very high if all of these individuals
are vaccinated but katie's point
the white house only cares about things
that it can benefit from politically
like during the during the election
kamala harris
anti-vax fear migrant the same with uh
with
joe biden and this is why the southern
border is a total free-for-all
with people covet positive illegal
immigrants coming in 900
what it was a 900 increase in rio grande
valley
uh that benefits them they think that's
great for them but look at what they
said about the
canadian border today they postpone
the canadian um border reopening for
canadians to come into the u.s
until august 21st canada is letting
vaccinated americans
into canada starting on august 9th so
why would they do that because they
don't it doesn't benefit them
the white house are they saying that
that vaccinated canadians can't come to
this country but unvaccinated migrants
can
illegals yes wow yeah actually it leaves
if you're legal you can't cross
not to cancel the border mexico no but
if you're illegal
it's wide open pretty much in a way they
put a wall up on the northern border
that is very interesting all right
harold square that circle it's a lot of
circle
so let me the the the texas
legislators something that something
doesn't seem right i would agree
you if if everyone's vaccinated uh
double vaccinated and you have this
there's a lot of questions that need to
be that need to be answered and i hope
your your show gets
yeah we're gonna get to the bottom of
that two um it's funny
the mask thing i hope we don't have to
go back to maureen mask i don't want to
go back to wearing masks
but the way to do it is we're not even
50 vaccinated as a nation yet
and i don't think there's anything wrong
with democrat republican like wherever
you may sit on the political spectrum
encouraging everyone to do it i actually
think for those of us and i'm a believer
more so now than i did before that this
is this virus is a result of a leak out
of that lab
that the way we get back at the chinese
is we all get vaccinated because we keep
our economy open we remain vibrant we
don't have to wear mask or the
likelihood of wearing mask is much
less and what more with those who want
to hurt us
like to see it in our economy stalled
kids not in school
and small businesses suffering we talked
about crime we got to do that but
but the mastering and the vaccination
thing are critical but we got to get we
got to figure
this thing out with these legislators i
don't understand i i don't i don't
disagree there will probably be more
headlines but there was one big
difference and i think we touched on it
a year ago we didn't have vaccines so
when people talked about
president trump and others who might
have had indoor set indoor events
happening
i think there is a there's a difference
there that should be noted the fact that
we have vaccines now makes it a
different conversation
do you think these fleeing texas
democrats feel bad at all for what they
did
i don't know i would feel so guilty
right now if they're watching fox they
would feel really bad
but they're not watching fox they're
watching cnn who's not covering this of
course you know it is a contrast
between how it shows what how corrupting
power can be so you have the media
politicians smearing the powerless right
citizens
you stupid rubes who who are skeptical
of the vaccine you're so
dumb you listen to right wing radio
meanwhile while they make fun of
citizens they create a moat of
protection around the politicians who
actually spread the disease
so they they it is always this thing
where they are somehow exempt from their
own
um their own i guess judgment that's why
they got into politics is to be
exempt from the rules that they can
create for others like private security
for example
and defunding but i do think you know uh
uh jesse
uh to be perfectly honest the real
victims here are people who must wear
masks at luxury massages
[Laughter]
there are a lot of married couples who
are wishing to go and enjoy a good
massage and
suddenly they're being told that they
have to wear masks